[Music]
whoever controls the oceans has the
power and here in the high North a new
ocean is being born
[Music]
I'm wandering through a graveyard of
American military equipment on the
largest island in the world
[Music]
like what I'm seeing here is just a
bunch of American Military
infrastructure that was set up during
World War II used during the Cold War
and now it's just abandoned like this
massive dish that was a part of the Cold
War defense in the Arctic that the U.S
used creating a chain of radar so that
if the Soviets invaded from the Arctic
they would be able to detect it and this
giant dish is one of those radar
boosters after the Cold War the U.S sold
this town and all of its buildings back
to the greenlandic government for one
dollar they didn't need it anymore
that's because the world was at peace
everything was good and the Arctic you
know was just a frozen place that now
with the Soviet Union falling apart was
not strategically that important but
things are changing
I want to show you what this looks like
what it actually looks like on the
ground here in Greenland get you up to
speed on everything you need to know to
understand what is certainly going to be
one of the most important geopolitical
issues for years to come increasing
tensions blooming war on the Arctic is a
massive military buildup happens in the
Arctic Circle could have far-reaching
implications for us all
I'm at an airport in rural Greenland
it's like in this Fjord system near the
village of umana and I'm realizing that
I need to let you in on something which
is today's video is sponsored by
storyblocks I've been using store blocks
for a decade long before I was ever a
YouTuber I was just a video maker and I
was using storyblocks that used to be
called the video blocks now they're
called storyblocks so I'm I'm able to go
out here into the field take all these
beautiful shots right I'm taking all
these amazing shots of Greenland most of
the time I'm not able to do this this is
an expensive thing to come out here and
get all these shots most of the time I'm
in my office making videos about the
world how do I do that
story blocks storyblocks is a giant
repository of visual assets footage
templates sound effects that you can use
to bring your story to life so for me
mostly that's the footage I go on the
storyblocks I type in what I need and I
get loads of results and then the best
part is I can download unlimited Clips
like you pay one subscription and you
can go buck wild and download as many
Clips as you want this is a very good
feeling for anyone who's had to pay to
license footage per clip or per second
storyblocks is just like you pay a
subscription it's a very reliable no
hidden fees reliable rate every month
and you get as many Clips as you want
this works for individual creators that
are small big this works for big
production companies like when I was
working at production companies or
different places I would use story
blocks like it's for creators production
companies of all sizes I use storyblocks
all the time and I'm really glad that
they have decided to sponsor one of my
videos I've actually thought of it I was
out here shooting and I was getting all
this amazing Drone footage and I was
like should get some of this up onto
story blocks so right now I've actually
uploaded a bunch of my own clips from
this trip from Greenland to storyblocks
these are gorgeous Clips I'm telling you
I got some of the best footage of my
life while I was here and a bunch of
that is up on storyblocks so oh and I
didn't mention this but StoryBox also
has After Effects templates like
animation templates that you can use to
start off your animations I know how to
do animation I love animation but I
secretly use templates all the time
because they make life so much easier oh
and they just put out this um plug-in
right in Premiere and after effects
where you can have like story blocks
inside of the editor so you're not
actually going to a website and
downloading you're just browsing story
blocks inside of the editor which is
like like mind-blowing what is happening
life is so much easier when you have
unlimited access to clips and assets
right inside of your editor so giant fan
of storyblocks over here really grateful
that they're supporting today's video
there's a link in my description it is
storyblocks.com Johnny Harris clicking
that link helps support this channel not
support surprisingly but it also shows
you how you can get in on this you can
go find what the pricing looks like for
you go get a bunch of my clips that I've
uploaded to storyblocks here from
Greenland and uh hopefully you'll be a
better stronger more versatile Creator
because of it let's get back to this
story because there's a lot to cover
I have been moving through Greenland
exploring this massive Island mostly
have been in the fjords in these rural
communities hunting for seals and birds
riding on dog sleds
getting to know how ice Works ice is way
more complicated than you can imagine
and the people here know it very well
and filling in my gap of knowledge it's
a gap of knowledge that I think a lot of
people have like a lot of people know
Greenland for memes about how little is
known about Greenland or maybe you know
it as the island that is always
exaggerated in its size by the Mercator
map projection but maybe that's probably
just map nerds who think of it that way
but anyway the fact is this place is not
very well known or understood but I'm
telling you that is about to change
[Music]
the top of our planet is a giant ocean
for centuries Empires who control the
oceans are the ones that had the power
but not up here this ocean has always
been frozen desolate and inaccessible to
powerful navies in search of power and
influence
so the Arctic has remained a
geopolitically quiet place this is one
reason why Inuit Traditions have been
able to stay alive here though that's a
whole nuanced subject and I went on a
deep dive in another video I made from
Greenland
the fact is that things are changing a
new man-made blanket of carbon is now in
the air and it's been trapping more and
more heat on our globe and warming it
just a few degrees but somehow enough to
change everything
[Music]
here's what the ice up here looked like
at its lowest point in the 80s and
here's what it looked like at its lowest
point last year yeah and this new ocean
in the high North is heating four times
faster than the rest of the planet and
where there are liquid oceans there will
be countries looking to control those
oceans the new shipping routes the oil
and gas the minerals and just generally
the opportunity to control and influence
a new place
so you've got Canada who's laying claim
to the Northwest Passage saying that
this valuable new shipping route Cuts
right through their territory and should
be theirs you've got Russia with all
these military bases dotting their
Arctic Frontier they're also claiming
all of this ocean all the way up to the
North Pole they even put a flag on the
ocean floor a few years ago the U.S is
spending over a billion dollars to buy
and build Icebreaker ships to patrol the
Arctic and even the rising super power
China a non-arctic nation is trying to
get in on the influence up here working
with their Ally Russia to create an ice
Silk Road investing 10 billion dollars
in projects across the Nordic region so
yeah lots of activity happening all over
this region I've just scratched the
surface on a few highlights here but the
fact is the Arctic is getting a lot of
attention and one major focus is here in
Greenland a place that has been pretty
ignored by great Powers until that is
there's something they need or there's
something to gain which is exactly
what's becoming the case as the ice
smelts and this new ocean appears
are you a global superpower looking to
project influence in the newly opening
Arctic look no further than Greenland
the gateway to the Arctic Ocean most of
Greenland this massive Island is located
conveniently within the Arctic Circle
this is why it was the chosen jumping
off point for Arctic explorers who were
trying to be the first to reach the
North Pole in the early 1900s in fact
the U.S recognized that this massive
Island was a smart geopolitical location
a long time ago convincing Greenland's
colonizers to help them evict an Inuit
community so that they could put an air
base up here the top of the world turned
out to be a perfect location to Traverse
their growing Empire and to spy on the
Soviets during the Cold War they even
had nuclear weapons up here for a time
and it wasn't just one base over the
course of the 20th century the U.S set
up a handful of military bases in
Greenland they used this island to put
up these massive radar systems which
would serve as early warning in case a
Soviet invasion came from the north and
now it just looks like a full-blown prop
from a Star Wars movie I mean look at
these
so Greenland's strategic potential was
clear but once the Soviet threat went
away the U.S mostly abandoned its
presence here though they still have
that base way up North and they've
turned it actually into the base of
their space force but they eventually
closed down their Embassy in the capital
and Greenland went back to being nothing
really useful to the great Powers just a
frozen Island at the doorstep of a
frozen ocean so Greenland this massive
Arctic Island at the Gateway to the
Arctic Ocean is now becoming much more
important that's because this ocean
that's always been frozen is melting
more and more every year opening it up
to new trade routes to new resources to
new versions of influence that can be
exerted at the top of our planet and so
great powers are once again paying
attention to this place because great
Powers no longer see a desolate Frozen
Island they see opportunity they see an
island perfectly located close to New
entire seen shipping lanes they see an
island with territorial Waters full of
new resources whose territorial claims
theoretically extend all the way past
the North Pole incidentally overlapping
with Russia and Canada they see the
potential of this place being a
repository of rare Earth elements the
stuff we need to build modern
Electronics like cell phones computer
hard drives and electric vehicles so
suddenly this place is becoming a lot
more valuable in the eyes of people who
want Power a fact that was highlighted
by a guy who spent his life sniffing out
real estate deals on land that was about
to become valuable Trump wants to buy
Greenland it's a large real estate deal
so the concept came up and I said
certainly I'd be strategically it's
interesting yeah that actually happened
boy that was a crazy four years I'm glad
it's over
anyway the point is that Greenland is
now getting loads of attention and
becoming much more valuable which brings
me here to perhaps the clearest symbol
of this renewed interest in Greenland
this is the
US Consulate in Nuke
after saying they planned to buy the
country the Trump Administration backed
down after Denmark was like hell no get
out of here and instead took a different
approach they ramped up efforts to build
relations between Greenland and the
United States Building Mutual economic
interests which resulted in the opening
of this consulate just in 2020. the US
now has a diplomatic presence a physical
presence in Greenland this big frozen
Island that no Global superpower really
thought was that important until
recently I'm pleased to announce we will
reopen our Consulate in Nook Greenland
this summer for the first time since
1953. so this actually reminds me of a
story I did a while back when I was up
in the Arctic for Vox borders and I was
visiting a Russian consulate on this
little island and it truly never ceases
to surprise me that in an era of like
sophisticated alliances and like
International institutions and like
sophisticated military Weaponry we still
resort to just putting human bodies and
buildings in places that we want to have
influence in like it's a board game some
things will never change but as the U.S
looks to deepen its ties with Greenland
so is another Power another Global
superpower one that incidentally is
nowhere near the Arctic but who knows
that if they want to be the Top Dog on
the world stage they're gonna need a
foothold in this new region a race for
resources could lead to a boil over a
lot of focus is placed on the Chinese
they do control a significant amount of
Supply we are so adamant that these
areas of the world that are the arteries
of trade and shipping remain peaceful
there is a worry of this Chinese
possible infiltration in the country in
2017 Greenland wanted to build more
airports like the one behind me that
they're building here in Greenland they
don't have a lot of infrastructure for
big airplanes so you can't get like big
commercial flights in and out of large
amounts of the country you have to fly
around in small planes and helicopters
which is kind of cool if you're like
going on an adventure but if you're
trying to develop your country you need
bigger airports the problem is building
airports is expensive and no one wanted
to fund this except for
China the prime minister of Greenland
went to Beijing their friend and said
hey do you want to help us fund our new
airports China was like yes we will give
you a loan to fund the airports but
it has to be a Chinese construction
company that builds the airports and
Greenland was like okay let's do it that
sounds great and immediately over in the
United States alarm Bells start going
off this is not good the context here is
that China has a habit of giving loans
to countries that they want to like have
influence in like in the future they do
this a lot in Africa like they give
loans knowing that they now have
leverage over all of these countries who
now owe them money anyway so the United
States sees this potential deal
happening between Greenland and China
and hates it Greenland this place that
is so strategically located that it's
right next to the United States that is
really a huge part of the future of
global influence in the Arctic suddenly
in debt to China No in fact the Pentagon
freaked out and was like What if
Greenland defaults on their payments to
China and China seizes the airports and
starts using it for their military a
little bit of an alarmist like Doomsday
scenario but it's true like when you owe
someone money they have over you the US
did not like this so the US goes to
Denmark and tells them to kill the deal
Denmark does it they agree and suddenly
Denmark is now funding two-thirds of
these airport projects
China got rejected on these airport
deals thanks to U.S pressure
but they didn't give up they started
setting their sights on those Rare Earth
minerals that we talked about earlier
the vital ingredients for your phone
your computer and your electric car
China holds a near Monopoly on mining
and processing these minerals so they
see Greenland as an opportunity to
continue that near Monopoly but also an
opportunity to access the Arctic another
place where they can compete with
Western interests it started when this
Chinese Corporation made a deal to fund
a zinc and Lead Mine in the far north of
Greenland it was all going to plan until
the Australian owners of this mine
suddenly decided to end their deal oh
and shortly thereafter they got a 650
million dollar check from the United
States to fund the project once again
the U.S blocked their rifle from getting
a foothold in the Arctic another Chinese
company has had their mining licenses
revoked entirely by the government of
Greenland so between this diplomatic
pressure as well as some local
anti-mining political sentiment China
has been blocked time and time again
from getting its foothold on this island
China's words and actions raised doubts
about its intentions Beijing claims to
be a near-arctic state yet the shortest
distance between China and the Arctic is
900 miles
so yeah the USA has made its stance very
clear that they don't want China a
non-arctic nation to be meddling in this
region to be gaining a foothold in the
gateway to the Arctic this region that
is opening up that is becoming really
important and in addition to blocking
China's efforts the US has also stepped
up their own efforts to get more U.S
influence and presence in this place to
prepare for the future of geopolitical
conflict
the U.S is doing Investments on its own
investing billions of dollars in
military infrastructure in this region
including a four billion dollar upgrade
of that air and space installation in
the north they're also committing to
military training exercise within the
Arctic the US Army has been sending
their soldiers to train in arctic-like
conditions to mimic What conflict might
look and feel like in the high North the
US government is offering millions of
dollars in Aid directly to Greenland to
help them develop their Mining and
tourism sectors so yeah once again we
see the struggle for influence playing
out between great powers in all of these
kind of hard to see battlefields loans
infrastructure blocking trade deals
diplomatic pressure military presence
this is kind of the flavor of modern
conflict I mean not the Russian flavor
of modern conflict but like the great
Powers conflict plays out in these other
ways these hard to see ways these
bureaucratic systematic ways
but who cares about these big
superpowers and what they want for
Greenland I came to the Capitol nuke to
talk to my friend kupanuk about what
greenlanders actually want after all
this is their Island they should decide
how it's used and by whom we are not
just looking at the Western world
through Denmark anymore but we'll see
him more globally so we're starting to
realize more and more how lucky we
actually are that's super interesting it
turns out that about half of
greenlanders actually think it's a good
thing that China is increasing in its
power and influence around the globe but
when you ask them specifically about
China Investing in Greenland they're
more hesitant with nearly 70 percent
saying that they oppose foreign
investment from China but a country like
Greenland which has such a fraught
history with colonizers also has
reservations about Western interests
here too and a lot of interest is have
been and are still being done in
Colonial and decolonial Nations more and
more things are just being shown now
because people are more aware of their
rights and more aware of the rights that
are being violated so green lenders are
waking up to their power in this
situation waking up to the leverage that
they have in this new Global competition
and while they might have their concerns
about China and the West they're looking
for the best deal for their country the
first ones must be our closest friends
and like-minded Nations and then if
other countries want to invest in
greenlands and in our way we are open
for business
so as we move into this new era of great
power competition the map is changing in
unexpected ways add to that the warming
globe that is creating a new ocean and
suddenly this island so often forgotten
by great Powers is now in a position of
Leverage there are many greenlandic
people who haven't realized how powerful
we can be
how march is like
I don't know how small Denmark is
without Greenland it's like she's a tiny
tiny country if they didn't hurt us we
should be more aware of it and be more
proud of it and realize how powerful we
can actually be in the future
foreign
[Music]